welcome to the course in this course
we're going to show you how to read your
body and other bodies so when you look
across the street you'll be able to pick
up what's going on inside by the outside
you're going to look at their eyes their
lips their nails and really have a deep
understanding of what is going on inside
now I want to just make a quick
disclaimer that we're not trying to make
a mini medical doctor out of you or make
claims to cure or diagnose any medical
conditions this is purely educational
it's entertainment ok so that's my
disclaimer now let's get right into the
course the first and most important
thing that you need to understand is
this one thing right here the symptom
does not equal the problem ok now in
medicine and healthcare what they've
done they made the symptom the problem
they collapse these two now if you do
that you're going to make the problem
last a lot longer and persist and I
think the reason why they've done is
purely financial because the whole
system is rigged to have you go to all
these specialists and put you on
medications and have you keep going so
what they do is they take this symptom
in and make it sound very complex and
very scientific like lembaga that's low
back pain arthritis pain in the joint
there's even a diagnose called dis
tatical Kinesis
that means inability to perform rapid
rhythmic movements ok so in reality
these are plain descriptions of what the
body is experiencing at the effect so
these are effects ok the effect is not
the cause now this is why I don't like
donating to a lot of the different marks
for the cures and the research because
it all goes to the same drug companies
that are not looking for a cure they're
looking for some drug to manage the
problem that's called managed care I
mean if you look take mercs manual the
the authority on diagnosis or a
pathology you're going to find that
almost every single diagnosis is
unknown the cause of it is unknown and
so that's why the one of the diagnosis
would be called idiopathic that means
unknown cause so the things don't just
come from no reason don't buy into
you're getting older it's always genetic
or it's just the way things are you're
going to have to accept the fact that
that's just how things are so the
symptom is not the problem the second
thing that's missing is this little
problem here with a lack of evaluation
when you evaluate you dig deeper you
find out an underlying root cause that's
what science is about it's about finding
the truth of something so we want to
evaluate want to investigate so what we
want to do is we want to ask questions
what kind of questions well if the body
has some dry skin if it has a red dot if
it's crack corners of the teeth if
there's bloodshot eyes if your hair is
falling out if you have high blood
pressure high glucose all these things
we want to ask a question why what is
the body trying to tell us and we want
to pull a string now you want to get as
much data as you can in this little
course that I put together I gave you a
lot of understanding of what certain
things mean nutritionally and whatnot
but we want to find out the biggest
question that I always ask over and over
and over again when it started okay so
we have when when did it start
alright because we want to narrow down
there's always something occurs right
before the problem started so we go when
and then what happened just before
that's going to give you huge what
happens what happened just before we
that's going to give you huge clues on
what's really the true cause of the
problem just before now if you just
these couple questions you will this
obvious answer will just pop right up
and it's like oh why didn't I think
about that when you find the true cause
of something it should be pretty obvious
it's not going to be some mysterious
thing I'll give you an example I had a
patient she had angina that's chest it's
a fancy term for chest pain and she went
to the doctor she went to the hospital
emergency care that they did all these
tests and they found nothing after
$40,000 worth of testing she comes in in
the first thing in equestria I asked her
I said when they start she said last
Tuesday I said what happened just before
that she goes ah oh that's right I went
out to dinner I said okay what else oh I
ate a banana split oh thank you do you
ever eat that she goes no never so she
ate this banana split that's going to
plug up her gallbladder which is right
next to the ducts to the liver and
that's going to back up the liver and
put pressure on the heart so all I did
is do a little tiny acupressure on the
bile duct okay which is right here and
chest pain went away never came back so
it's very very very sane and very simple
these these simple questions here so you
have also you have a diagnosis called
out with complex regional pain syndrome
what is that that means that when you
have surgery and you still have pain
after the surgery they call that complex
regional pain syndrome and I've so many
people coming in for that they're doing
fine till they have the surgery and now
they're in pain now I'm not against
medicine or doctors or any of that I'm
against the system it's set up what I
want you to do is ask questions find out
why don't be satisfied with well you
know I'm the I'm the doctor you're the
patient find out you know that's what
we're trying to do so we have the
symptom and we have the problem we have
the effect now when you ask this
question what happened just before the
symptoms started there will always be
well not always usually one of four
things
all right number one it could be
something they ate that they shouldn't
have eaten okay that's that's probably a
big one right there or it's something
they should have eaten but they didn't
eat people that never eat anything green
except pistachio ice cream lime green
jello that was MIGO going into college
so it's eating or not eating all right
so that's going to give you a lot of
clues and by the way I do up if you look
to the right of the screen there's a
little button about if you press it
you're going to get into a survey about
my course called the health course
certification it's called a health coach
certification and I get into what you
should be eating I teach health coaches
on what they should be training their
clients on what to eat and this entire
method right here and a lot more in
depth but in this little presentation
I'm just going to give you some of the
basics but there's more to know so
number two can be related to stress
stress I mean if you ask a person what
happened just before they had this
problem the stress of it let's just take
wait delivering birth you think that's
stressful
big time that's stressful on the mother
it's stressful on the baby carrying a
baby for nine months that could have
threw off the body and made you gain
weight um I'll give you another example
I had a guy just coming today he got
hugely fat right when he stopped smoking
that was the change now that was a
stress event now you're going wait a
second no it wasn't you're taking smoke
away from them but actually smoke
actually the nicotine relaxes the
adrenal glands and it's actually a
stress reliever I know it sounds weird
all the smoke doesn't help but when they
stop smoking they get real nervous and
they actually the stress goes up so the
stopping the smoking shock the adrenals
and he got really fat happens all the
time so stress but it could be in anbar
you can be in a situation where you're
being stressed out at work or where
you've been through a stress event or a
loss
my goodness you really almost every
single client that I that came in here
with MS for example multiple sclerosis
they had a stress event or a loss right
before they got it
so autoimmune diseases get set up with
losses because it's a major stress in
the body so we have stress and then we
have environmental factors environment
and that could be an exposure to
pesticides herbicides fungicides that
can be exposure to a toxic relationship
with your spouse or a relative of
something like that
I think everyone usually has one
relative who is very toxic but the
environmental stress can be quite quite
big or you know being exposed to
radiation you know if you just close to
your noble that could be an
environmental stress and then number
four is going to be a lack of sleep okay
so we got this sleep it's usually not
sleeping too much it's basically getting
a lack of sleep if you push your body on
three or four or five hours of sleep you
are going to break down faster you're
going to have a health problems you're
going to be tired
it's a lot of stress on the heart and
then if you add exercise on top of that
you really push the person over the edge
but a lot of times I'll have people come
in with all of these problems right here
you know what's really bizarre is
there's there's very little attention
put on these four things in health care
I mean this is could you imagine if they
focus on these I mean the relationship
between what you eat and how it affects
your health is huge the only way you're
going to create a healthy body is by the
nutrients in the food that you eat but
there's no attention put on those foods
or nutrients I'd even even developed
some software to analyze the nutrition
in your diet and rarely do we have
anyone that is even close to getting
enough so pretty much all my clients
when they come in they're not eating the
right things they're eating too much of
the wrong things or their body is this
one big stress ball
they're in environmental toxicity and
they're not sleeping okay other nuts are
perfectly healthy so I want to make this
very very simple to you because it
really is once we find out and ask these
questions then we can find get the
remedy that the true cause so we want to
define the cause and a cause would be
you can't go any deeper like I had a
lady she said um I was depressed I said
describe that to me she said oh I feel
just really tired I'm like okay maybe
it's fatigue maybe it's not depression
she goes yeah I'm kind of tired in my
head I said well what made you think
you're depressed she goes well that's
what I was diagnosed I said you know
what you're just tired she goes wow I
feel a little bit right now
so the symptom is not the problem we
want to use the symptom as a string or a
clue to understand the real problem
cause effect we want to evaluate we want
to find out what's the body trying to do
we want to understand when it started
what happened just before it we want to
look at the four factors right here and
then when we find that main thing boom
we can plug it in as a remedy and the
person is start getting better okay
so in the next video I'm going to show
you a little technique on how to get rid
of any pain anywhere in your body all
right so we're going to talk about that
and also I'd like to invite you to
actually be a health coach and what the
health coach training is it's an eight
week course which is all online it's
like an hour to a week it's not that
hard you'll be doing homework it's very
interesting but if you like the ability
the ability to help people and you like
to figure things out you can take my 25
years of blood sweat and tears and
summarize it in an eight-week course and
learn the basics and actually some help
either do it full-time part-time or just
as a hobby okay so I invite you to take
the survey to my left and actually
become a health
all right so I hope you enjoyed this
I'll see you the next video good luck